congratulations kevin you are the winner
of big brother canada season 10.
how are you feeling right now thank you
i feel amazing incredibly humbled so
happy last night i didn't i'm a
processor it takes me a while to take in
emotions yes very shocked and confused
and now that
their reality is set up yeah so you're
now a hundred thousand dollars richer
what do you plan on doing with the money
i'm gonna do i'm gonna do safe things
with it i'm gonna invest some of it i i
i'm gonna donate a little bit i'm gonna
donate ten thousand dollars to cause
close to me but uh hopefully
the rest i'll be smart with
okay so let's talk some game what was
going through your mind when josh picked
you over betty
to take to the final two
i thought he better i was
i was putting in the work to get josh to
take you to the final two for 30 plus
days as soon as we started working
together i was making the case to him
that i had losing finalists written on
my forehead that my game was too
invisible and nobody would see what i
was actually doing and i was pretty sure
that josh was planning on taking me yeah
if you had won the final hoh instead of
josh though who would you have taken i
would have taken betty
helena and i were under the impression
that josh was this massive jury threat i
thought i was losing to josh saying in
the final two until the votes were read
i thought i had to win that final hoh
and take betty um
so i'm thankful that i was wrong about
that perception
for all your scheming and strategizing
and what do you think was the most vital
component of your game play that led to
your win
i actually don't think it was lying i
think the best part of my game play was
having tough conversations yeah i have
been afraid of conflict at times in my
life but actually i find that
when you lead with empathy when you can
have those tough conversations and speak
openly it actually often leads to
good things and that's not manipulation
that's just having the tough
conversations and being open to
listening and working through them yeah
you were working in your duo alliance
the ghosts um what was the first thing
that she said to you after your
win she i don't even know i i think
orisa pulled us together and said you
did it and i and you don't know how
anything's perceived on on the outside
so yeah to see that we were actually a
thing and this actually was in the show
it was great and then
i think helena just said we we did it
you did it i don't know but she i
i i owe her everything i owe her my game
she went to hairy house
and if it
and i
almost wish it was her in some ways we
were that close to the house wow
you pretended to be married all season
um could a real wedding be on the
horizon with you and jillian
if if if she's into it i'm into it i
think uh give us give us a few months to
maybe get engaged let's see what happens
okay no i'm gonna get back to real life
no promises yet but certainly
i've been manifesting it for 70 days
right like that was part of the life so
let's
um so you're the winner of big brother
canada without ever winning an hoh which
is insane uh what do you think is more
important a strategic game or a physical
game
i think you need both in most cases
apparently i didn't i did have one veto
win for the record but
i think for a balanced game you do need
both and fortunately i had a jury that
was open to someone who was really
strong strategically and not that strong
on the comp side of things but every
season is different this one winning hoh
tended to be a terrible thing for most
people and because i was focused on the
strategic side of the game i was able to
come out on top
okay if you could sum up your big
brother canada experience
in one word
what would it be
fun
oh
it was the time of my life i had so much
fun every day i knew that my chances of
winning were actually not that high
you have a one in 16 shot right so i
said every day i'm just gonna try and
enjoy each moment and appreciate the
experience and and i i really did
awesome congratulations kevin enjoy it
have fun
you know make it rain all the things
should i make it rain
i mean
safely i mean just just you know get a
little budget you know just you know
keep it
keep it together now don't go crazy
because make it rain doesn't line up
with my do safe things with the money
but it does sound really fun it's it's
really fun just like a little temporary
rain it's a little like a hail like a
quick little hail and ow
okay
little spitting situation
yeah